so I had a dream yesterday that I had a
six-pack and I was running half naked on
a beach with two girls running next to
me and they wanted me for my mind and
not my body then I woke up and I
realized hey what's going on YouTube now
recently a subscriber told me about his
very interesting situation recently I
just got a girlfriend and she doesn't
like it when I hang out with my
homegirls who have been around with me
for 10 plus years I don't know what to
do about it I really like this girl but
I don't want to get one of my friends
what on earth
what a [ __ ] now from an outside
perspective when you hear about the
situation through your words the first
thing everybody wants to do is just pop
out but you can't because you have to
take a step back and assess the
situation now if you're the type of guy
or girl when you get with somebody and
all you do is hang around that person
you never really run into these
situations but there are a lot of people
like you yourself who do have a lot of
homeboys or homegirls and when you get
with somebody it makes that person feel
uncomfortable so first off let's talk
about boundaries
number one prior to you guys actually
getting together did she know that you
had a lot of home girls that you've been
friends with for 10 plus years because
if you did is she still tripping you
ever heard of elephant tranquilizer you
know I'm so [ __ ] mad at ya [ __ ]
whatever you know my dear let's think
about this with perspective you just
came into the picture you're brand new
mind you they had been friends now for
years prior to you coming into the
picture so just because you're here what
do you think there's something gonna
start [ __ ] in a toilet how crazy
would that be be seriously is your life
a Korean drama it's not because just cuz
you're here suddenly they're not gonna
be like nah well I'll just use a goodbye
oh no I doubt that's going to happen
number two you have to ask yourself how
little do you trust him how can you just
get with someone and you guys had barely
began your journey as a couple and
already you don't trust him there will
be plenty of time for you guys in the
future to get at him when he [ __ ] up
and a hundred percent of the time it
will be his fault but until that time
comes where she does not put the [ __ ]
toilet seat down no matter how many
times you've asked him nicely you've got
to give him a chance and this is just a
side note somehow you and I got a
girlfriend I don't know how but praise
the Lord hallelujah benefit of doubt and
assume that you're a [ __ ] scumbag so
you need to ask yourself this is your
relationship with the other girls
appropriate like small things a couple
of the girls that you're hanging out
with did you used to date them and if
you did she should probably know about
that you spend time with them more than
you do with her if that bothers her then
you should probably talk to her about
that the girls that you hang around with
touch you inappropriately and if they do
good on you for my personal experience
in a relationship depending on the
person that you're with you know you
might have to change some of these
boundaries for her if she's worth having
and if you feel that you want to touch
this person be with that / and then and
that's who you are that's okay too you
just got to find somebody that
understands that about you
if you establish these boundaries and
the communication is clear then there
shouldn't be a problem but to this guy's
girlfriend I can only assume because it
just came from his side he's seeking for
advice obviously he doesn't seem like a
scumbag and you should be confident
enough to know that you my dear are a
strong and beautiful individual that you
have enough to hold your own that you
don't need to feel insecure about some
other [ __ ] actually not [ __ ]
they're his friends don't call them that
that's [ __ ] so start trusting each
other start communicating with each
other and strut that [ __ ] that's not a
saying is it walk a flock of the
kockenlocker
do they touch you inappropriately and if
they do lucky you